This year, Thailand has seen a striking turnaround in its laws on illegal drugs.
Until recently, the kingdom's harsh penalties would see...
…hundreds of foreigners locked up on long sentences,...
…but now, the government has completely legalized the use of marijuana,...
…released thousands of prisoners,...
…and as our Southeast Asia correspondent, Jonathan Head, reports,...
…sparked off a boom in weed related businesses.
The cannabis craze is sweeping Thailand.
See how beautiful it is?
This is the country's health minister,...
…the architect of what's now one of the most liberal marijuana regimes...
…anywhere in the world,...
...being cheered by enthusiastic locals...
…who hope that this green gold will bring them new wealth.
It is an astonishing turnaround for a country,...
…that still has some of the toughest punishments for drug use.
We have already destigmatized these products from being narcotic.
People, when they have access to this cannabis industry,...
...they will not go to the dark side.
They will only focus on how to make a better living.